okay someone's getting fired blood
[Music]
what's going on my name is Jax Jones and
this is snap Wars for lad by amor
oh yeah I love Japan how'd you propose
to my wife before flying there it's like
magic or not it's called a grilled you
Nagi ill nigiri the trick is to have
more fish than carve that's why they
stay slim
unlike the nation I don't like you so
this might be unpleasant it's kind of
cute that they've wrapped it it's like
an eel prison happy birthday to me
I didn't sign up for this [ __ ] man
someone's getting fired below
but those who don't know I'm not pork
pies it's just a newly indulgence for me
when I'm home alone and it's been a long
day in the studio I drop in a pork pie
so yeah man you don't want to read the
contents though this piece it's a bangle
pun intended
I'm gonna finish it you already know who
the winner is the dry pork pie
well the ear was that bad why here we go
Hey
another classic big got the squad now
these guys will be making a comeback
we got Fred old I used to get two pound
of wheat pocket money from about spend
it on this when he was Tempe and I heard
they've gone up in value maybe due to
inflation and that Breck see it whatever
it is these I've had these before these
are red bean ma cheese and again they
look like they've been contaminated I
understand you wanted to make it easy
for me to open this is a piss T like a
marshmallow with the jam filling with
Asian desserts it's not usually what you
think it's gonna be so let's investigate
Moorish this is just bringing back good
memories still looks the same
ain't age one being zypher Oh
freddo in it what is agus RG agus why is
it so much I am what's this the
alternative is I feel like this is like
seaweed or maybe like peppers and it
contains boiled salt water no this is
bleak what what why wouldn't you give me
bread Oh after this this doesn't make no
sense is this like a delicacy in it I
don't understand why you'd look forward
to eating okay
[Laughter]
Wow a blunt why here we go just quick
ting rice tastes like a Berk in
basically the winner is my dong the
loser is haggis this would actually work
in like Happy Meals am I in a burger
here we go
it's a surprise perfect
why is it called Romany bottle hmm so
what's that
ha ba ba ba here we go oh that's it
I'm enjoying that all right cool I'm not
really like her what is this like a beer
oh it's an ale
I'm not really an old guy I feel like
ice man from South London are really
tough enough to drink mysterious here we
go
tell you what yes smooth we got John
Smith but for me the winners Ramu we got
Japan you did big Tings ma'am yeah ma'am
I'll be out there sampling these
delicacies maybe I first of all let's do
it
can I keep this off